(exhales forcefully)
But it's not crocodiles
I should have been
watching out for.
Instead, it's one of the most
temperamental animals out here.
(hippo snorting)
Wow, there are a lot of eyes
looking in my direction,
a lot of ears pointed
in my direction.
They know I'm here.
Hippos kill more people
than any other large animal
in the entire world.
Being so packed together
in such limited water,
they're stressed and ready
to defend their territory.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Look at that one.
It's starting to come up,
it's starting to come up.
-(hippo bellows)
-Oh, oh, oh.
Just showing me their jaws,
showing me their tusks
that could literally cut
a man in half.
(hippos grunting)
They're telling me
to back off.
Hippos are dangerous
in and out of the water.
They can run
up to 22 miles an hour.
And in this area,
I need to keep a lookout
everywhere around me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Here's what I'm talking about.
The ones that are up on land,
those are just
on the land feeding,
which means there could be
more out here.
That's when they get
really dangerous.
Okay, time to go.